it's time for a serious game
so
i think i'll do random challenge overall
random challenger
okay so three plus two so it's blitz
but i'll still try and take this
seriously
and i'll play
i'll play my english repertoire
which is actually a
repertoire that i
i don't play so often on stream but it's
something
i kind of save for tournament play
because most people don't know me as an
english player
and we'll go from here
so never played matmap before matmap
five
um
yeah one of the benefits of an english
is it's kind of like a sicilian
but upper tempo and okay i'm playing my
main main repertoire a3
still theory the main move is g3
at least like mainline theory
so a6 i'll play e3
black wants to set up uh like bishop c5
to a7
i will say bishop c5 is a mistake
we'll see if okay so it happens
this is this is still prop
the idea now is um
i'm taking over the center
if knight takes e5 i have d4
i had this position once in a tournament
game but instead of the pawn on e6 it
was on a5
it doesn't really make a difference
though black is losing back a piece
tournament game was probably in like
2015 or 2016.
my opponent played bishop d6
which walked into c5
uh with this move okay now it's time to
think
because i can take the knight or the
bishop
probably better to take the bishop
keeping the bishop hair
and keeping initiative against a knight
knight moves
okay so i have some options here i have
queen d4
but the knight c6
a b4 bishop b2 which looks really nice
and the structure is all already set up
in a way where
b4 makes a ton of sense
thank you javier
i'm doing my best not to uh
get too distracted by chat
so a5
it's still equal material still gonna be
a fight
and there's my time better too
there's b5
there's various knight moves to exploit
this knight
actually like the prospect of knight d5
takes and queen takes
and then the knight is hit twice
and just pure initiative here so takes
takes knight here and then b5
and then knight here and then queen
queen g5 f6 bishop c4 king h8
and some move like queen g3
because d6 is natural there
because the line is very possible to
happen there's also knight g6
after which h4 and if takes i have queen
h5 and
each file battery comes to life
h4 is very much justified
very common whenever there's a nylon g6
to
just advance h-pawn
that's automatic instinct to take back
but i should should consider this move
as h5 takes takes takes my mating
seems close but not quite
this takes if king h8 is mating because
rook h7 queen h5 but rook here
maybe not quite
another idea is to just play bishop c3
the knight has to move and then queen g5
g6 queen f6 is mating
if f6
again i check king h8
it's a judgment call i think i'll play
this
i'm just gonna have to move back
either one
yeah
and now queen g5
there's also queen d4
and queen d4 is a little bit safer
i have three plus two so i have enough
time
okay i've kind of forgot about now the
five live queen g4 g6
and some like e4 move just remove the
knight from
hovering g7
if ever takes like bishop c3
rookie won that line of bishop e2
the problem with like calculating deeply
is
yeah it takes more time than usual
it's important my king's on a dark
square so it can't be checked by the
knights
bishop e3 or bishop d3 probably does the
same thing
oh there's also this move bishop g7
knight g7 and h6 but then there's this
move
i mean f6
so i should play bishop c3
d5 will play this no need to um
oh wow there's d4 here
d4 is a great move
maybe this move
h6
what's going on there
uh-oh
oh no my serious game
i'm so down on time
don't hurt me
these pawns kind of scare me
okay i think i'm winning now bishop h7
what a move
and black had queen d2 check but
hey it's checkmate okay
oh the attack worked out
that was a close one
i spent so much time calculating i
almost flagged
okay
did i fulfill the
fulfill the challenge of playing a
serious game
i was trying to like show some nice
lines i used something like
my main opening crap too